apple has just announced another event
on november 10th
titled one more thing and in this video
i'm gonna explain why this is one of the
most important events
that apple has ever hosted and why they
could actually be making history
so before we get into that i want to
talk about everything that you should be
expecting
to get announced or released and i'll
show you guys a bunch of leaks and
rumors
that point to those things so let's get
right into it this event is 100
going to be focused on the new
game-changing apple silicon max
that apple announced back in june when
they said that they'll be releasing
the first of these macs before the end
of the year
well this event is precisely for that
they're going to spend a good amount of
time talking about the history of the
mac
they're going to announce the release
date of their new mac os 11 big sur
and then they'll reveal the new family
of apple silicon chips
based on the a14 bionic chip which will
be going into
some new macbooks and future macs and we
know we're getting macbooks for sure
because of apple's ar
invitation teaser for this event which
shows an apple logo
opening up like a macbook but before we
get into the products
let's talk about the apple silicon mac
chips if you don't already know
these new chips are going to be
replacing the intel chips that apple has
been using for the mac for many years
now
so essentially future max will be
powered by the same type of chip
that you already have in your iphone or
your ipad
now there are a few benefits to this the
main one is that these chips use a much
simpler architecture
compared to the complex x86 architecture
that traditional intel chips use
because of this they get a huge boost in
performance per watt
which leads to much better battery life
and less heat
output currently even macs like the 2020
macbook air
have overheating problems and loud fans
and all of that is going away thanks to
these new apple silicon chips
now i'm not going to spend this entire
video explaining apple silicon
so i'm gonna link to our dedicated
playlist at the
end of this video but just to give you
guys a sneak peek
these new chips are gonna change the
entire computer industry forever
starting with thin and light laptops
that will eventually ditch
the x86 architecture this is literally
history being made at next week's apple
event
but now let's get back into what to
expect from these new chips
as well as which products apple is going
to announce
because there could actually be more
products than just
the new max according to china times
both
apple's a14 and a14x processors
are already being mass produced at tsmc
and while we already have products like
the iphone 12 and ipad air 4
with the a14 chip apple has yet to
reveal
the a14x chip which is why we have the
november 10th event
and based on our benchmarks the a14 chip
is extremely impressive
because it's giving us the best single
core performance we've ever seen in any
computer
and the multi-core performance is almost
as high as the a12 z
chip but the shocking part is that the
new four core graphics
in the a14 is more powerful
than the a12z's eight core graphics
which shows us just how good this new 5
nanometer architecture
is and based on our own estimates the
new a14x chip has the potential
of outperforming apple's 2400
16-inch macbook pro in terms of graphics
power
which is absolutely insane now getting
into the products
based on recent rumors we should most
likely expect
two different macs to be revealed and
released at this event
the first one is rumored to be an
entry-level macbook that's meant to
replace the current 13-inch macbook air
now this could either be a revival of
the 12-inch macbook
that apple discontinued last year or it
could use the same body as a 13-inch
macbook air
but they could simply just call it the
apple macbook
and it's going to be getting the a14x
chip that will likely be
rebranded with a new name now i
personally believe that we're more
likely to see a 13-inch display
compared to a 12 inch and that's because
the very reliable leaker
love to dream just tweeted that we
should be seeing
two 13 inch macbooks being released at
the event
now the other 13 inch macbook is of
course the new
13.3 inch macbook pro which might not
have that many
changes apart from having a new apple
silicon chip
now i believe that for this mac apple is
going to be putting in a
slightly more powerful or upgraded chip
potentially a 12 core instead of the 8
core
a14x like chip that's most likely going
into the other lower end macbook
or if they don't go that route they
could potentially give the macbook pro
a more powerful gpu or extra hardware
accelerators
compared to the other macbook earlier
this year
apple updated the 13-inch macbook pro
but they only gave
the more expensive 1800 model the new
10th gen intel processors while leaving
the base model
mostly unchanged this shows that the new
13-inch apple silicon max
will be replacing the base model and
apple might keep the 1800
model the same with the 10gen cpus
until next year when they bring out the
new 14-inch
redesigned macbook pro with apple
silicon
now before i move on i do want to talk
about the leaks about
this 16-inch macbook pro now i
personally believe
that the apple silicon version of that
macbook will
only come out next year alongside the
redesigned 14-inch model
but there has been leaks and rumors of a
final
10th gen intel-based 16-inch macbook pro
coming out this year we already have
some leaked benchmarks of a 16-inch
macbook pro with a new intel 10 chen
chip and if they are true that means
that apple could be releasing it this
year
and the only time that makes sense is if
they release it
before the november 10th apple silicon
event
so what i'm trying to say is that
there's a chance that we could be seeing
an updated 16-inch macbook pro as soon
as
tomorrow but there are no guarantees and
on top of that there's a chance that
apple could put out
one more final imac pro with new intel
xeon processors and most importantly big
navi graphics sometime before the end of
the year
but we're just gonna have to wait and
see now to make things even more
interesting
harker tech found some code in a beta
version of mac os
big sur that points to three macs being
released
in 2020 now we know two of them will be
the new lower end macbooks
but the third one could potentially be
an intel-based
16-inch macbook pro or that imac pro
or it could actually be the rumored
apple
silicon 24 inch imac this new imac has
been rumored for months
and while the 27 inch imac got updated
this year
the 21 and a half inch didn't get
updated so we're
most likely to see the new imac with
apple silicon
replacing the 21.5 inch model what makes
it even more interesting is that there
is rumored to be
a new a14 t-chip and a dedicated apple
gpu
being made specifically for this new
imac
but a lot of the rumors are pointing to
it only coming out next year
so there's a chance that apple could
either announce this imac at next week's
event
but set the release date to next year or
they could just ignore
it and not mention anything about it
until 2021
now beyond these new apple silicon macs
there are a couple of products that we
should expect to see as well
the first one is apple's new air tags
and the leaker john prosser is
very sure that we'll be seeing them
announced on november
10th saying that they're on schedule for
release alongside ios 14.3
which is supposed to be coming out this
month and we should also be seeing a
leather keychain carrying
case for air tags as well which is
pretty cool
there's also the chance that we could be
seeing the release of the new airpods
studio
over ear headphones which john prosser
leaked a few weeks back
now apart from all of that there is
still a very small chance that we'll be
seeing apple announce
a new 12.9 inch ipad pro with the new
a14x
chip since it would be really weird to
show off the a14x chip
but not release the ipad pro like they
usually do
but on the flip side most of the leaks
are pointing to a release of a new ipad
pro
next year so i guess we'll just have to
wait and see so there you guys go
hopefully this video helps you guys
understand a bit more about what we
should be seeing
next week at apple's event and if you're
excited go ahead and click the circle
above
because we're going to be buying those
apple silicon macs testing them
comparing them and everything like that
so
definitely subscribe and check out our
apple silicon mac
explained playlist right over there
thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you in the next video